Speaker 1: I have an amazing clip of another one
of these Republican hearings backfiring terribly.
Every single one of these just goes so, so,
so wrong, radical and repugnant. Republican
Congresswoman Lauren Boebert from Colorado.
She was asking questions to. Q Ron Abuja. I
don't exactly know the right pronunciation
of the name, but I hope that that's close.
Kiran is the director of the U.S. Office of
Personnel Management. And Lauren Boebert was
going after her because of the number of federal
employees not logging in to work based on 2020
data. The only problem, 2020 was a different
administration run by a guy named Donald Trump.
Speaker 3: You're not aware of any employee taking
something that one would consider a vacation time
and bringing their computer and maybe logging
in just a portion of that time or not at
all. We have we have more than 25% of federal
employees not logging, not logging in to work,
and they're teleworking. Congresswoman, I do
take issue with the characterization that 25%
of individuals are not if it's in this leaked
document right here that we just submitted into
the record. You're basing that
from 2020, which is in the last
administration and I can't speak to that your ten.
Speaker 1: Isn't that the best? So first of all,
Boebert is trying to make a point with data
from a different administration. Okay, that's
funny. But the really funny point is, despite
all of her praise for the Trump administration,
the thing she's really angry about here,
the thing that Lauren Boebert is trying to
pin on Joe Biden's director of that agency
actually applies to her Lord and savior,
Donald Trump's administration. Previously. The
this is not the first time that this has happened.
A lot of these people, they talk about 2020. You
know, I genuinely don't know whether they're just
morons or whether they've forgotten or they're
confused. I know that there was a 2020 election.
There was an election in 2020, but it took place
in November. And the people who won in November of
2020 didn't start working until January of 2021,
including Joe Biden. So they have many times a
lot of things didn't go great in 2020. You might
remember, inflation was starting to go up, gas
prices were going up, all these different things.
And they go, listen, what? Look at these numbers.
Look at what happened after Joe Biden was
here when he was elected in 2020. Right.
But Biden wasn't in power until the end of
January of 2021. I don't know if they're
doing this on purpose to deceive or whether
they're clueless or whether they're morons
or something. Combination of the above. But it
just keeps happening again and again and again.